Vous vous demandez peut-être : « Qui va payer ? »
Eh bien, je soutiens que c'est aux gouvernements
de financer les infrastructures sanitaires.
Les ONG et les associations caritatives
font de leur mieux, mais ça ne sera pas suffisant.
C'est aux gouvernements d'assurer le financement des sanitaires,
au même titre que les routes,
les écoles, les hôpitaux,
ou d'autres infrastructures, comme les ponts,
parce que nous savons, et c'est l'OMS qui a mené cette étude,
que pour chaque dollar investi
dans les infrastructures sanitaires,
nous récupérons entre 3 et 34 dollars.
Revenons sur le problème de la vidange des fosses.
À l'Université d’État de Caroline du Nord,
nous avons mis au défi nos étudiants de trouver une solution simple,
et voilà ce qu'ils ont trouvé :
une simple vis sans fin modifiée
qui peut remonter les déchets
de la fosse jusque dans un bidon collecteur,
et maintenant il n'est plus nécessaire
de descendre dans la fosse.
On l'a testé en Afrique du Sud, et ça marche.
Il faut encore consolider le système,
et on va faire d'autres tests
au Malawi et en Afrique du Sud l'année prochaine.
Notre idée est d'en faire
un service professionnel de vidange de fosse,
de façon à créer ainsi une petite activité,
avec des emplois et des bénéfices,
et nous espérons
qu'en repensant l'hygiène sanitaire,
nous augmenterons la durée de vie de ces fosses,
sans avoir recours
à des solutions d'urgence
qui n'auraient pas de sens.
Je pense que l'accès à des sanitaires adaptés
est un droit humain fondamental.
Il faut arrêter de condamner
ces personnes de caste et de statut social inférieurs
à descendre dans ces fosses et à les vider.
Nous en avons le devoir moral,
social et environnemental.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)